is there a rule which you didn't write
in the original list of 42
that you wish you'd put in there
oh set aside some time for play
that's probably that's one
um can i make a suggestion from your
work sure
it's from a lecture that you gave and
it's written on my wall over there
and it's don't practice what you do not
want to become
oh yes yes that's that's that's
that's uh
yeah i have a corollary of that too that
works in relationships
do not punish what you want to have
happen
so so here's an example imagine that you
that
that you've married someone that you
find attractive
and then imagine that other people find
that person attractive as well
and that that's actually somewhat
threatening to you
and then instead of dealing with the
fact that you're threatened by the very
thing that you were attracted to
and that you're blessed to have you
start to
punish the person that you're with when
they manifest themselves as attractive
well you do that for 10 years and the
attractive person is no longer there
and then you're going to be angry at
them even though it was completely your
fault
you know because if you punish someone
for the manifestation of a desirable
virtue it
really hurts them and you because people
are
you know it's so interesting to watch
what happens when people stop me on the
street
especially if they're shy and maybe
somewhat damaged
they want to tell me about something
good they've done
but they're very hesitant about it
because their experiences being that
if they reveal something good they've
done they either get ignored or punished
and so they don't want to do it they're
afraid but
if they do it and then they get a reward
well they're they're unbelievably happy
about that
but that's a good example because it's
very common for people to experience
punishment for their virtue and you know
you can do that with your kids too if
you're jealous of them i mean maybe you
have a kid who's really bright he's
brighter than you
it's like are you so sure you're happy
about that
and how do you know that you're not
going to punish that child because
you're jealous
you know and if you think you're not
that sort of person well you should
think again
because people are that sort of people
and
perhaps you can train yourself not to do
it but envy is a pretty common human
emotion and the probability is that
you're reasonably prone to it
but so one of the things i learned again
from animal behaviorists
skinner in particular skinner believed
that
he's the psychologist who was most
famous for learning
experiments with rats he believed that
the best
form of discipline so if you want to
train an animal to do something was
reward you waited till the animal did
something that approximated what you
wanted and you immediately rewarded it
so maybe he would train a
rat to climb a ladder and then walk
across the top of a ladder down another
ladder and
well he just watched the rat and
whenever the rat went near the ladder
he'd give it a food pellet and soon it
was near the ladder all the time
and then being near the ladder you know
it would put a leg on
a front paw on one rung bang food pellet
well soon the rat was going like this
and then the next thing you know it was
going like this and he could i mean
a good animal behaviors can train an
animal to do an amazing thing any
number of amazing things in your
intimate relationships
if you watch the people that are around
you and then you see them doing
something that
they should do more of and i don't mean
this in a manipulative sense because
hopefully
if you have any sense you're rewarding
them for something that would also be
really good for them
and you say look i saw you do this and
that's really good
do more of that it's like man you're
just
opening up the pathway for that person
to deliver what you want if you'll admit
what you want if you'll reward it when
it happens if you pay proper attention
if you think you deserve what you desire
if you think your ideals are worth
pursuing if you have any faith in
yourself i mean all those things have to
be
explored and answered but it's
unbelievably powerful
and that's all dependent on well moral
orientation and
the capacity to pay attention
absence of cynicism thank you very much
for tuning in
if you enjoyed that then press here for
the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
makes me very happy peace
you